the United States says it is now
convinced that this was the work of Iran
the weekend attacks on two massive oil
production plants has had a global
impact economically and could be about
to shift the security dial across the
region with these satellite images and
others which the US is keeping
classified American intelligence
analysts claim that cruise missiles were
used not just drones and that they were
fired from Iran not Yemen in the red
boxes holes are visible they are
according to US officials piercings made
by the missiles there are at least 17
impact points one of the two sites was
toured by Saudi energy minister Prince
Abdul Aziz bin Salman although state TV
didn't show any images of the damage
other than declaring that the attacks
had temporarily cut the country's oil
production in half we still don't have a
clear idea of how bad the damage is or
how long the facilities will be out of
action a spokesman for the Saudi
military said their initial
investigation at the sites tallied with
the u.s. assessment and I said hell if
he thought most of the weapons that were
used in a terrorist attack whether it be
an AB ke Kaku Reis initial evidence
shows that these weapons are Iranian
weapons and we are investigating this
the Iranian president rouhani is in
Turkey at the moment at a regional
conference the Glasgow educated lawyer
and cleric gave little away at the photo
op in Tehran a government spokesman
denied any involvement we reject these
types of statements and projections the
Islamic Republic of Iran has clearly
declared that it supports the people of
Yemen and their rights but to accuse
Iran of these attacks and defensive
measures is in line with the u.s. policy
of maximum falsehood back in June the
United States claimed Iran had shot down
one of its drones Donald Trump called
off at the very last minute a
retaliatory strike on Iran now he says
his military is locked and loaded again
the Iranian judgment may well be that
he's bluffing because domestically he's
after re-election not another war in two
tweets the US president said first that
he was waiting to hear from the king
as to who they believe was the cause of
the attack and under what terms we would
proceed and then the Iranians say they
had nothing to do with the attack on
Saudi Arabia we'll see tonight in New
York the US ambassador used the UN
chamber to echo her government's
accusations against Iran as Secretary of
State
Mike Pompeo has clearly stated there is
no evidence that the attacks came from
Yemen emerging information indicates
that responsibility lies with Iran it's
also emerged today that Iran had seized
another commercial vessel in the Gulf it
accused its crew of smuggling fuel to
the United Arab Emirates it is still
holding a British flag vessel seized in
July all of this together amounts to a
dangerous escalation with wide
implications economically and for
regional peace mark stone Sky News